[Musique]
les forces de l'ordre sont intervenues
pour deux rêves parties dans la nuit du
dimanche 19 au lundi 20 février la
première était organisée à Versailles la
présence d'une cinquantaine de personnes
a été constatée par les policiers
quelques heures plus tard c'est à HR
qu'une rêve partie a été signalée une
quinzaine de personnes étaient présentes
aucun accident n'a été signalé mais les
organisateurs ont été conduits au
commissariat des perturbations mais
cette fois du côté des lignes de train
sur Twitter la SNCF a annoncé des
difficultés sur la circulation des
lignes l Égypte pendant les vacances
scolaires du 20 février au 5 mars en
raison du manque de personnel le trafic
devrait reprendre normalement le 6 mars
samedi 18 février des militants de
Greenpeace et d'autres associations
étaient mobilisées pour une action
nationale au travers de 37 villes de
France dont Versailles au programme de
la soirée action d'extinction des écrans
lumineux et des enseignes le but réduire
les consommations d'énergie
inutiles à l'heure de la sobriété
énergétique nous nous sommes mobilisés
pour recouvrir les panneaux
publicitaires lumineux qui restent
allumés nous demandons à au gouvernement
d'interdire les panneaux numériques de
publicité ils sont très énergivores ils
consomment beaucoup autant qu'un foyer
en un an sileng constate qu'à Versailles
l'extinction des insignes lumineux et
plutôt bien respectés ils souhaiteraient
que le gouvernement interdise totalement
les panneaux lumineux et que les
enseignes soient éteintes quand les
commerces ferment avis aux fans de sport
maintenant d'après nos confrères de RMC
certaines épreuves des JO 2024 en
extérieur et disposant de place debout
seraient accessibles gratuitement dans
les Yvelines il devrait s'agir du BMX
Racing du VTT ou encore du golf à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines depuis le
début des tirages au sort le 15 février
de nombreuses internautes se sont
indignés face au prix excessifs des
places pour assister aux épreuves et on
termine avec cette information insolite
le plus célèbre couple de souris était
de sortie samedi 18 février à l'espace
Saint-Quentin de le Bretonneux tout
l'après-midi les mascottes ont défilé
pour le plaisir des enfants et des
familles à l'occasion de cette journée
deux places étaient à gagner pour le
célèbre parc d'attraction un moment
féérique qui a rassemblé de nombreux
curieux dans le centre commercial
[Musique]